LEO, LARRY -- BY THE WAY, I WANT
TO LEO-LARRY SHOW, LEO 2.0.
WE DO HAVE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO HIS DOCTORS, WELL,
HE IS EXPERIENCING ZERO COVID-19
SYMPTOMS, ON A SPEEDY ROAD TO
RECOVERY AND WE CAN HOPE AND
PRAY THAT CONTINUES FOR
EVERYBODY THAT CONTRACTS THIS
INVISIBLE ENEMY.
APPARENTLY MANY NEW YORKERS
THOUGH, THEY HAVE BEEN
BRAINWASHED BY THE MEDIA MOB AND
THINK SOMETHING CONSPIRATORIAL
IS AT PLAY.
JOINING US NOW WITH A FULL
REPORT, HANNITY 2020 ELECTION
CORRESPONDENT, OUR VERY OWN
LAWRENCE JONES.
LJ, WHAT DO WE GOTTEN A?
>> GOOD EVENING, SEAN.
AS YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT IS
BACK AT THE WHITE HOUSE
RECOVERING FROM A CORONAVIRUS
BUT HE’S NOT FINISHED WITH HIS
AGENDA IN FACT, HE’S GOING ALL
IN.
AFTER MONTHS OF NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE DEMOCRAT FOR COVID
RELIEF, HE ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT
HE WOULD BE ENDING THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HIS FOCUS NOW
WILL ALL BE ON HIS SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE AND TO GET THAT NOMINEE
TO GET CONFIRMED.
BUT SOME DON’T BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT EVER HAD IT.
THEY THINK IT WAS ALL A HOAX.
WATCH.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE HE IS DOING
PRETTY WELL NOW THOUGH, BUT HE
STILL HAS COVID.
>> I’M STILL A LITTLE CAUTIOUS.
>> IF I RAN INTO SOMEONE WHO I
KNEW HAD COVID TWO DAYS AGO AND
WAS IN THE HOSPITAL, I WOULD
PROBABLY WANT A LITTLE
SEPARATION.
>> SOMETIMES I WONDER IF IT’S
JUST A PLOY.
>> YOU THINK IT’S FAKE?
>> TO GET PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
HIM, TO GET PEOPLE TO FEEL SORRY
FOR HIM.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
>> UNIVERSAL.
SOME PEOPLE SAID IT WAS A HOAX,
I DO BELIEVE THAT?
>> NO.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIND EVERY
REASON THEY CAN TO PICK ON HIM
AND THIS IS JUST ANOTHER ONE.
>> WHY WOULD HE PRETEND TO HAVE
COVID?
>> MAYBE LATER ON HE WILL HAVE
AN EXPO NATION AND TO PUT TWO
AND TWO TOGETHER.
HE SAID HE HAD CORONAVIRUS.
>> WE NEED TO FIND SOMETHING TO
REUNITE US AND IF THE PRESIDENT
IS SICK, ALL OF THE CITIZENS
SHOULD BE COMING TOGETHER
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
LIKE HIS POLITICAL STANCES.
HEALTHY PRESIDENT IS A HEALTHY
COUNTRY.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE, IT LOOKED
LIKE THAT BROTHER AT THE END WAS
THE ONLY PERSON THAT HAD A BIT
OF COMMON SENSE HIM AS SAYING
NEED TO UNIFY ON THE PRESIDENT